-My first guest is
an Oscar-winning actress
who stars in the Hulu series
"Nine Perfect Strangers."
The finale begins streaming
tomorrow.
Here is the one and only
Nicole Kidman!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness. Come on now.
Oh!
Ah, so happy to see you, Nicole.
You look gorgeous, pal.
Thank you so much
for coming to see us.
I appreciate this.
-I wish I was there in person.
-I know. Well, next time.
Next time, you're going to be,
I know it.
I know it's gonna happen.
-I will come in. Yes, I will.
-I know you love New York
and it's a very special place
for you.
You got engaged here,
I know that.
I know -- Didn't you?
Yeah. Do I know that?
-You're not meant to know that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I'm allowed to know
all the stuff.
I know all sorts of stuff
about you.
When did you first -- when did
you first -- did Keith Urban
just sweep you off your feet?
When did you know?
-He sat on the stoop
of my New York apartment.
I came out 5:00 a.m.
in the morning,
and it was my birthday
and he had flowers.
[ Audience aws ]
And that was it.
I was a goner.
-That's how you do it.
-I'm like,
"Yes, I'll marry you."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And you just celebrated
15 years, right?
Your 15th anniversary?
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
For a second there, I thought
you said 50 years.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Going back in time.
-Hopefully, one day.
-Yeah, exactly.
-But, yeah, 15 years, which is
pretty amazing, right?
-It's the greatest.
-Yeah.
-Did you do any party
or any surprises --
No, you don't like surprises.
I know this.
-No.
-I know this.
I don't like surprises either.
-No, I do not.
-Why not?
-You don't?
-No, I really do not --
-I mean, I don't mind
a surprise,
like something kind of sweet,
but I don't like
a surprise party.
It's too -- I had
a surprise party once
and I broke out in a cold sore
on the spot from the shock.
[ Laughter ]
I literally did.
It was too stressful.
It was like I was seeing --
It was apparitions.
It was bizarre.
I didn't like it at all.
-Every now and then, I like
a surprise, but not a big --
it has to be a small one.
I feel like it's like I'm
tricking someone or something
and I don't like to do that,
so I feel weird --
I don't like surprises.
I like to know what's happening.
I'll act surprised.
-Yes.
Yes, we know that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did I just burn you?
[ Laughs ]
-Would you ever -- Because I've
seen you sing with Keith before.
Would you guys ever
do a duet album?
-No. No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Why? Why?
-Because you have to --
I mean, I have this thing
where just stay in your lane,
right?
[ Laughter ]
I shouldn't be trying to get
into his lane.
I'm fine where I am.
-Okay, yeah. Okay, yeah.
-So yeah.
-So it would never happen.
-And also I just -- I don't feel
comfortable singing.
I have sung but it's not really
what I feel comfortable doing.
-So you wouldn't perform
in front of crowds
like Keith plays
arenas and stuff.
Yeah, he goes on tour,
and he's amazing.
-Yes, he's playing Vegas
right now.
-Is he really?
He's unbelievable.
-Which is why I couldn't be
with you because I chose him.
I mean, in terms of the Vegas
and it's -- Yeah, to be here.
-Would you --
[ Laughter ]
-Shut up, Nicole.
-Dude, I can't even write this,
I swear.
I can't write this.
What are we doing?
-What are we doing?
[ Laughter ]
Ask me something good.
-I will. Come on.
-Sorry.
-I am. I will.
[ Laughter ]
Just stop it.
-Now I'm like, "What?"
-Just chill out.
Just calm down for two seconds.
Gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Nicole, I want to talk to you
about what you're amazing at,
which is acting, and you're also
producing "Nine --"
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, really, every single day
you come out with -- It's like
you just keep proving yourself,
and you're like, "Oh, okay,
she's the greatest."
It's another one
that's a slam dunk.
"Nine Perfect Strangers." It's
the new "it" show right now.
It's on Hulu.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People love it.
Everyone's talking about it.
-Yes.
-The finale streams tomorrow.
Can you set up what
the show is about?
-This show is
such a trippy ride.
-Yeah, it is.
-Nine strangers check into
a wellness retreat,
which is run by me.
-Yeah.
-I play a Russian-American
woman, and her name is Masha.
-Yeah.
-And we treat the people
for their depression or their
trauma or any of the things
that they're going through, and
it's sort of this crazy ride.
And the finale happens to be
my favorite episode.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, so that's kind of good.
But it gets crazy.
It all goes down
in episode eight.
-I heard that you stayed in
character the whole time,
by the way.
-I did actually,
which was really weird
because the other actors, I only
met them on the first day,
and I had met Melissa previously
and Bobby,
but I never really gotten to
know anybody in the cast,
which was kind of great,
so I just stayed as this
Russian woman and related to
everybody through my character.
-Wow.
-And it was actually weird
because I didn't get to
really know them as Nicole.
I got to know them as Masha,
and on the final day, a number
of the people were like,
"Gosh, we've never even heard
you speak
in your Australian accent."
-Wow.
-I would go up and hug them
and I would stroke them.
[ Laughter ]
And I would stroke their hair
and listen to their stories,
yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Nicole Kidman
in the finale of
"Nine Perfect Strangers."
Take a look at this.
-Who are you?
-Who am I, Heather?
♪♪
I am a person who had somebody
who was at their center,
and when I lost her, I lost me.
I am a person
who is living her life
defined by grief
and pain and loss.
I am you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
Every single time,
you are phenomenal.
The finale of
"Nine Perfect Strangers"
begins streaming tomorrow.